bonjour pascal dupont merci de répondre
à nos questions ce matin sur rtl france
accorde donc des 27 pour un retrait en
une heure des contenus à caractère
terroriste sur internet un consensus qui
met fin aux divergences ou qui les
masques plus tôt j'ai l'impression que
c'est un peu un coup devant on fait du
vent autour de cette histoire de
propagande jihadiste sur les réseaux
sociaux ou ailleurs la vérité c'est que
ça peut avoir un effet exactement
inverse celle que les jeunes types qui
sont déjà marginalisées dans un résident
radical salafiste ou autre comme le col
est interdit selon dale envie d'attaquer
encore plus fort donc ces
contre-performances ça les excite
il ya d'autres formules possibles et
notamment il ya des gens qui aujourd'hui
se bat contre la radicalisation et le
salafisme et c'est ces gens là sur le
terrain qu'il faut aider voilà cette
proposition doit encore être
formellement adoptée par le parlement et
par le conseil européen
qu'est ce qu'il peut se passer d'ici là
sur vous je sais pas qu'il y ait des
parlementaires qui est justement comme
moi considère que c'est faire du vent et
que ça peut effectivement des excités et
que ces contre performances
donc je veux pas me mettre dans le dans
le jeu de ces discussions parlementaires
mais je pense que c'est effectivement
pas très malin il ya des mais des
modèles plus intéressants à suivre
et je pense au danemark dont je parle
dans mon livre il se trouve qu'à une
ville au danemark deuxième ville du
danemark ce qu'est la russe dans le la
province du soum hollande
il récupère les djihadistes avant qu'il
parte ou à leur retour ils font un deal
avec eux après les avoir checké on punit
pas on n'est pas en prison mais on se
met au boulot et d'intérêt
à le faire bien sinon effectivement
c'est la taule et ça marche vraiment
bien les gars et les filles jihadistes
sont suivis par des mentors
c'est super malin et c'était une petite
entreprise dans le moulin ben arous où
ils ont un gros gâteau très
problématique
et c'est un modèle à suivre je crois
l'objectif selon le rappelle un de
supprimer tous les messages haineux dans
l'heure qui suit est ce que c'est
réalisable et si oui comment réguler la
toile en 60 minutes
je peux pas répondre à cette question ça
me paraît aberrant
parce que vous interdisez quelque chose
il ya un site qui se créent dans l'heure
qui suit on sait que c'est pas
contrôlable donc monsieur da manha a des
bonnes idées mais celle-là est
potentiellement la meilleure je crois
que c'est pas c'est pas jouable et je
pense qu'il ya mieux à faire
en france on simple conseil
constitutionnel a déjà invalidé la loi
avia qui est proposée elle aussi de
supprimer ce genre de message la jugeant
contraire à la liberté d'expression
liberticide
à partir de quand on a le droit de
supprimer un message sans heurter la
liberté d'expression la réponse vous la
connaissez à partir du moment où on
devient agressif par rapport aux
convictions de la personne qui est en
face il faut il faut arrêter et donc
facebook fait cette police déjà en amont
besoin de se substituer telle instance
et agressif sur les convictions
personnelles d'une des gens que ce
soient leurs convictions religieuses ou
leurs convictions sexuelle ou je ne sais
quoi
facebook fait déjà mais le ménage donc
pas besoin de le faire à leur place je
crois merci pascal dupont d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes journaliste et auteur du livre
le retour impossible
aux éditions first à